هذا المخيم الان
كيف الخيم ثم بعد ذلك المساعدات هي كبيره
جدا بالاضافه ايضا في المقلب الاخر من هذا
المخيم هنالك مطعم كبير يستوعب الالاف
يوميا من الاشخاص يقدم لهم الوجبات
الساخنه ويقدم لهم المشروب الساخن كما
يقدم لهم ايضا بعض
اللوحات الترفيهيه للنشاطات اللاصفيه
للاطفال كالغناء وايضا الرسم على الورق في
المقرب الاخر بالاضافه ايضا الى ان هنالك
تجمع كبير لكل ما ياتي من الشاحنات
المحمله بالمواد الغذائيه او بالمواد
التموينيه او بالبطانيات او بالحرامات
بالاضافه ايضا كما اشرت الى مركز طبي داخل
هذا المركز يقدم المعونات الطبيه
يريدها ان كانت طبابه في امراض عاديه ولكن
الحالات الصعبه هو لا يقدمها وايضا هذا
المركز تحول في بعض جوانبه الى مخيم
للعمال الذين هم في الاصل من عمال المناجم
الذين اتت بهم الحكومه للمشاركه في عمليات
رفع الاوقات لما لهم من خبره في ذلك مخيم
كبير جدا كانت له
له الفضل الاكبر في الايام الاولى لاواء
عشرات الالاف
من الاتراك ثم بدا بعد ذلك بدات الامور
تخف به لان عمليه التوزيع الناس الى
المناطق الاخرى او ايضا الى
بلدات اخرى او الى محافظات اخرى هو ما يتم
وهو ما تم